bonsoir à tous comme chaque semaine
france info et l'ina vous offre un
voyage dans le temps à travers les
archives de la télévision pour décrypter
l'actualité notre dossier du jour est
consacré à une tradition bien de chez
nous mais pas franchement conseiller en
ce moment la bise et puis nous parlerons
navigation comand les courses à la voile
ont participé au développement de nos
transports alain thébault inventeur des
navettes siebel et notre invité vous
regardez l'inattendu et vous êtes les
bienvenus monsieur bonsoir je voudrais
regarder la franche au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup de jeunes apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins et si
vous ne réussissez pas ce qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le front ses valises à paris de
ce qui lui arrive à la baule à mes côtés
ludivine lopez et richard poirot
journaliste à la rédaction de l'ina
bonjour à tous les deux vous avez
sélectionné deux sujets d'actualité qui
résonne particulièrement quand on les
regarde en pensant ou en voyant les
archives richard
vous revenez sur la candidature de jean
luc mélenchon à la présidentielle ça
c'est l'actualité du jour puis s'est
déclaré dimanche donc candidats et
notamment il a dit ceci à la télévision
quand tout va mal et que ça semble être
nuit noire il faut allumer une lumière
pour qu'on se dise qu'il ya un bout du
tunnel alors je sais pas trop si la
lumière celui ou pas mais nous ça nous a
fait penser à une archive de 1987 c'est
une des premières apparitions de
mélenchon à la télévision et la lumière
à l'époque pour mélenchon
c'était françois mitterrand le président
le président il bataillait il était
jeune sénateur et il bataillait pour que
le président se représente
jean luc mélenchon 36 ans le plus jeune
sénateur de france dirigeants des
socialistes de l'essonne entend incarner
la nouvelle génération du ps résolument
à gauche est décidé à imposer une
nouvelle candidature mitterrand il faut
arrêter cette espèce de danse autour du
totem françois mitterrand voulez-vous
être candidat françois mitterrand soyez
candidat
je crois que ça c'est une conception de
la politique qui est complètement
archaïque
on attend que un personnage se déclare
je crois que sa candidature est
tellement importante pour se payer pour
la gauche qu'il faut en créer les
conditions et c'est ça que nous essayons
de faire il faut donc ils participaient
complètement je vis pas d'attendre que
françois mitterrand disent oui ou non
voilà sa première télé on n'a pas trop
changé déjà j'allais vous dire
finalement il a pas beaucoup qui se
pressaient toujours foule l'actualité en
novembre ludivine c'est aussi plus que
jamais j'allais vous dire la santé ins
et le mois sans tabac oui à moi sans
tabac un peu particulier à nathanaël
richard cette année d'ailleurs sur son
site la dépêche du midi pose la question
le confinement est il une bonne occasion
d'arrêter de fumer
les avis sont mitigés quoi qu'il en soit
moi cette actualité ça m'a fait penser à
une archive qu'on aime bien partager à
la rédaction de l'ina c'est une archive
d'un autre temps une époque où l'arrêt
de la cigarette était loin très loin
d'être une priorité
je vous laisse découvrir cet art chez
nous sommes en 1950 ces images vous vous
cache pas vous risquez pas de les revoir
à la télévision en allemagne des
fanatiques tenant de l'herbe à nicot ont
organisé un concours de tabagie dont les
participants devaient plus mais 20
cigarettes en une heure et ne laisser
subsister de chacune qu'un insignifiant
mégots
l'atmosphère était parait-il y respire à
malgré le brouillard on a trouvé le
champion
les vingt cigarettes en 42 minutes et
pas même deux fois offert une avec ceux
qui restent
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vous mêmes à chaque fois que
cette archive je suffoque totalement
voilà faut arrêter de fumer
alors ça c'était pour l'actualité des
derniers jours mais sinon que s'est il
passé le 11 novembre c'est le zapping de
l'ina ça s'est passé un 11 novembre
regardez bonjour général de gaulle et
monsieur winston churchill s'incline
devant la dalle le soldat inconnu à
monter pendant les quatre ans de notre
milhas you sa garde et vigilants déjà
ils sont abandonnés
cet énorme complexe militaire construit
à la taille de l'amérique est
proportionnelle à l'effort de guerre des
mesures et peut-être que les états unis
ont placé ici au vietnam
les sud vietnamiens vont venir occuper
cette base un peu comme on enfile un
vêtement trop grand soin rafa tu étais
allé le chercher malades en palestine
elle le ramène chez lui pour qu'il
repose en paix j'ai présenté à son
épouse à sa famille à ses proches mes
très sincères condoléances
c'est la première fois depuis la fin de
la grande guerre de 14-18 qu'un chef de
gouvernement allemand se trouve présent
sous l'arc de triomphe pour la
commémoration de l'armistice
colonie portugaise
jusqu'au 10 novembre à minuit nouvelles
républiques africaines
le 11 novembre à zéro heure écoutez nous
faudrait le reportage de vraiment grosse
non c'est pas possible on peut rien de
sortir on est en grève les grévistes ce
sont des femmes
ils sont 35 chargé de répertorier
classer fichiers divers reportages entre
un technicien et une analyste
il y à 500 francs de différence de
salaire allant gauche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir ya demain notre dossier de
l'inattendu ludivine vous avez choisi de
nous parler d'une tradition bien de chez
nous un aujourd'hui la bise oui parce
qu'avec les gestes barrière elle a pris
un sacré coup dans l'aisne
notre big nationale un coup dur pour les
amateurs comme moi de tout ou bisous
bécaud appelez la comme vous voulez en
tout cas j'ai pu me consoler
heureusement avec avec les archives r je
voulais vous montrer quelques quelques
images du monde d'avancé c'est byzance
et tu en voilà plus savoir quoi en faire
c'est pas ce qui manque en tout cas à la
télé un lobby un symbole français qui a
ses codes je vous le rappelle d'ailleurs
but nathanaël richard vous êtes plutôt
une deux trois quatre ou cinq disent ça
dépend des régions exactement ça dépend
d'un jeu mais nous nathanaël partout et
par tous enfants partout
ok ok c'est un peu ambigu en tout cas
chaque région on vous l'avait dit
nathanel à cette habitude on commence
par la joue gauche ou par la joue droite
bref pas facile de s'y retrouver quand
on vient de l'étranger d'ailleurs en
une journaliste allemande tentait de
percer le secret de la bonne bouffe
française regardez
en allemagne on se donne la main où on
se serrent dans les bras si on se
connaît bien mais normalement nécessaire
pas la bible
un allemand qui arrivent en france est
alors confronté à plusieurs problèmes
d'abord on fait combien de bize trois
bises à paris oui en normandie ces deux
dans la salle un peu plus basse et de on
vient du sud de la seine-et-marne donc
dans une ville qui s'appelle moret sur
loing et ont fait 4 biz ont fait deux
bises chez nous debise on a fait
beaucoup pour se dire donc bonjour pour
se dire au revoir pour se dire merci la
bise en france et enfin c'était partout
tout le temps
il y aussi à la télé on vous allez le
voir des bises légendaire d'ailleurs
celle-ci celle qui va suivre
c'est léon zitrone qui va vous la
présentez nous sommes en 1979 dans
l'émission une fenêtre sur lors de la
réconciliation solennelle entre la
france et l'allemagne après trois
guerres en trois quart de siècle le
général de gaulle et le chancelier
d'allemagne fédérale
conrad adenauer se sont embrassés et st
c'était un baiser qui avait une
signification très profonde alors
tellement légendaire à cette bise
convient de voir qu'elle est aujourd'hui
dans les livres d'histoire aujourd'hui
les divines symbolique ou pas la bise
bas s'est terminé 1 jusqu'à nouvel ordre
en tout cas distanciation sociale oblige
une situation exceptionnelle mais pas
idée du temps dans le passé la bise a
déjà été menacée exactement
c'était en 2009 à lors d'une précédente
épidémie celle de la grippe a
la maire de la ville espérait déjà
interdire la bise à ses administrés la
nouvelle avait fait grand bruit et les
journalistes s'étaient déplacés dans la
ville et vous allez le voir l'idée de la
mer n'était très loin de faire
l'unanimité
tous les ans il ya la grippe qu'elle
soit baissée ou juba co
ça changera pas le problème si on veut
dire bonjour jai avant le jeu par un
bisou et voilà comment qui vont faire
les petits jeunes qui flirte c'est fini
ils vont pouvoir draguer vous avez bien
c'est pas facile de s'attaquer au nom à
la bise en france finalement à l'époque
ni la grippe
annie lahmer de guilvinec n'auront eu
raison de ce rituel français faut dire
que ce rituel à de fervents défenseurs
jusque dans les couloirs de l'assemblée
nationale en 2007 un célèbre député
parlait bisous avec une forte passion
c'est un coup de saint mary's c'est
formidable
sas a déjà déclenché des sentiments
extraordinaires donc vous pouvez pas
réfléchir on n'a pas le temps
vous avez reconnu à le député jean
lassalle d'affaires dans militants de la
bonne bise à la française et qui doit
être bien malheureux frustré oui oui il
est bien malheureux
c'est un collègue comme bon nombre
d'entre eux en tout cas moi
personnellement je suis assez assez
frustré et d'ailleurs pour réchauffer
les car je voulais vous proposer une
petite chanson un peu cliché je vous la
corde mais pile dans le thème
[Musique]
g
en cas de shu
attention sur le nez c'est vous voler
sur l'eau un rêve partagé par les
skippers du vendée globe qui viennent de
prendre le départ le record de cette
course à la voile autour du monde en
solitaire et sans escale et de 74 jours
il pourrait être pulvérisé cette année
désormais les voiliers nouvelle
génération s'élève littéralement au
dessus de la mer on va en parler dans un
instant avec notre invité alain thébault
architecte naval père de l'hydroptère
c'est lui qui a donné des ailes aux
bateaux mais d'abord richard expliquez
nous qu'appelle-t-on un voilier volant
ce sont des bateaux qui s'élève
au-dessus de l'eau vous l'avez dit
carrément il décolle alors ça concerne
essentiellement la génération des
nouveaux voiliers des sables d'olonne on
les a vus partir des sables d'olonne
donc dimanche dernier et ils ont quelque
chose sur le flanc accrochez vous pouvez
le voir là ça ressemble à des moustaches
en fait ce sont des feuilles et c'est
vraiment la grande nouveauté de cette
édition 2020 ces folles c'est comme des
ailerons et ils agissent sur ces bateaux
là comme les ailes juste sur sur l'avion
en fait ils font décoller le bateau on
le voit c'est absolument incroyable ça
me fascine quand je vois ces images là
voilà regardez voyez il décolle
carrément au dessus de l'eau est
vraiment donc l'idée générale c'est de
d'échapper à la résistance de l'eau et
pour aller plus vite
alors nous avons la chance d'avoir en
direct de suisse l'un des pères de ces
voiliers à foil un système développé
fiabiliser grâce à l'hydroptère que vous
avez créé alain thébault bonjour alors
c'était dans les années 90
est-ce que vous ne pouvez nous rappeler
l'origine de ce projet à écouter de de
tout temps les marins ont rêvé de faire
voler les bateaux alors on a vu cette
transition il ya la sentant dans le ciel
on est passé des dirigeables aux
aéronefs et sur l'eau à la voile c'est
une idée que je partageais avec eric
tabarly
voilà on voulait mettre deux petits
folle sous les bateaux donc on avait
notre papier nos caran d'ache ont
dessiné et puis c'est vrai que quand
vous avez des ailes dans l'eau qui
soulève le bateau vous diminuez le frein
dans des proportions très importantes
vous avez environ 30 à 40 % de frein en
moins par rapport une coque qui restera
immergée vie chère quand est ce que les
français vont découvrir l'hydroptère
l'enfant d'un à tvo 192 à la télévision
française dans un gîte est un bateau qui
vole c'est sûr que c'est inattendu
sa coque ne touchent pas l'eau ses deux
flotteurs non plus difficile de dire si
l'hydroptère doit être exposée au salon
nautique ou au salon de l'aéronautique
la vérité c'est que cette maquette au
tiers n'obéit plus aux principe
d'archimède mais aux lois physiques qui
permettent aux avions de voler son
secret 3 aileron qui soulève le bateau
ces trois plants porteurs s'appuie sur
l'eau comme une aile d'avion s'appuie
sur l'air à l'origine du projet un
breton de 29 ans alain thébault c'est
lui qui pilote ici l'appareil en baie de
quiberon
voilà ce breton de 29 ans que l'on vient
de voir sur les images c'est vous alain
thébault en 90 92 pardon l'hydroptère
était une maquette il a fallu attendre
quelques années pour le voir
véritablement prendre la mer c'était au
début des années 2000 pourquoi tant de
temps est-ce que les obtint des
obstacles et et techniques ou était ce
une question d'argent on les obstacles
étaient à la fois techniques financiers
quand on est passé des dirigeables aux
aéronefs ça s'est fait sur quelques
dizaines d'années
donc il faut à la fois de l'audace il
faut de l'imagination et puis il faut de
la technologie donc quand on a des quand
j'ai dessiné drop terre je n'imaginais
pas que mes camarades airbus et dassault
construit sur des charges de l'ordre de
20 tonnes par mètre carré à 50 noeuds
quand on a battu le record mondial de
vitesse à la voile
on a des efforts de l'ordre de 35 tonnes
sous notre siège donc ce sont des
efforts tout à fait considérable des
efforts supérieurs à ceux que l'on
retrouve sur une voilure d'airbus et
tout ça au départ on ne l'avait pas
imaginer justement alain thébault vous
allez vous attaquer au record de la
vitesse sur l'eau ça se passera en
septembre est un mois de septembre 2009
vous allez battre ce record pour la
première fois un bateau à voile
un voilier va dépasser les 100 km heure
avec son équipage de dix hommes le marin
a enfin atteint son objectif dépasser
les 100 km heure sur l'eau 55,5 noeuds
exactement soit plus de 102 km heure une
pointe réalisée sur 500 m
le bateau est devenu l'engin vole le
plus rapide de la planète le record
absolu de vitesse à la voile est
désormais notre c'est vraiment une
oeuvre collective fantastique
un projet qui vise la aériennes
maritimes et bateau flotte est désormais
voleront c'est un moment important pour
vous j'imagine alain thébault vous vous
souvenez de ce moment je me souviens ce
moment vient bien évidemment parce que
ça correspondait à 20 ans de travail
on s'est crashé trois fois on a chaviré
une fois j'ai failli tuer plusieurs gars
et il y avait un petit grain de folie
donc ce sont des choses dont on se
souvient aujourd'hui je suis le papa de
trois filles deux garçons j'ai cinq
enfants
donc j'essaie en fait de passer d'un
projet de ce rêve de faire brûler bateau
à un projet industriel
alain on va reparler dans un instant de
la finalité de cette aventure de
l'hydroptère mais d'abord richard avons
l'hydroptère des années 90-2000 d'autres
marins ont testé le fog
oui en fait mais vous l'avez rappelé
tout à l'heure alain thébault ça date
d'il ya très longtemps s'adapte même du
début du 20e siècle
mais c'était à l'époque c'était sur des
petits catamarans s'était pas encore des
gros bateaux et les folles sur les
voiliers destiné à la course au large
ça c'est très récent et il y un pionnier
plutôt un défricheur vous en avez parlé
alain thébault c'est eric tabarly à la
fin des années soixante dix le marin
français va se lancer dans la
construction d'un trimaran équipés de
feuilles pour les compétitions au large
alors je vous propose de voir un
document assez exceptionnel ça se passe
en 1976 on voit tabarly sur un petit
trimaran à foils
c'est une maquette alors on est dans les
préparatifs les images sont les images
qui passent à la télé et elle sont
commentées à la télévision par tabarre
lui-même lui-même
et vous allez entendre la deuxième voie
c'est michel drucker on va vouloir
expérimenter seront large de la rochelle
de prototypes un prototype
oui enfin c'est un c'est un petit bateau
en réduction fait c'est à peu près la
réduction au tiers du projet définitif
parce qu'il vaut mieux faire les
expériences avec des petits bateaux
comme ça qu'ils coûtent pas cher qu'avec
quelqu'un bateau de 17 mètres
bon ça veut dire que sur une course
comme celle que vous avez gagné la
transat en solitaire
vous pourrez gagner beaucoup plus de
temps alors j'espère oui parce que ça
c'est un bateau enfin la vitesse
oui enfin c'est surtout pour essayer de
gagner une course donc il faut c'est
arrivé avant les autres on voit très
bien le bateau d'école des murs est
assez fort c'est un projet que vous
aviez depuis longtemps ça je l'avais
depuis depuis deux ans
voilà ça c'est émouvant et trois ans
plus tard en 1979 le projet aboutira
alors il aboutira presque et un bateau
va être mise à l'eau c'est le paul
ricard et il mesure 16 mètres
rien à voir avec le nord là c'est
vraiment mais ce qu'on va voir là sur
les images c'est que c'est vraiment un
monstre des mers on le voit
effectivement on voit les folles sur les
côtés voilà on le voit là vous voyez là
les foils sur les deux coques
extérieures les deux flotteurs
donc c'est vraiment avec ce trimaran il
va battre des records dans l'atlantique
mais en fait les folles vont surtout
servir à stabiliser le bateau il va
jamais vraiment décollé avec ce bateau
c'est pour ça que c'est difficile de
parler de foil en fait tabarly ne va
jamais réalisé son rêve qui consiste à
voler avec un bateau alain thévoz vous
avez très bien connu à eric tabarly vous
avez travaillé avec lui dans les années
80 vous débutez à l'époque ses goûts en
quelque sorte qui avait repris le
flambeau des grands trimarans à foil
avec l'hydroptère qu'elle marins étaient
tabarly eric tabarly c'était à la fois
un visionnaire et un est un grand
monsieur qui donnait une chance à chacun
aujourd'hui dans la société française il
ya beaucoup de fractures
il ya une élite avec des x et des et
dark et on ne donne pas lâcher une
chance au jeune erik embarqué sur pen
duick même des gars comme moi un jeu m'a
dit mais où est ce que tu es vite j'ai
dit j'habite dans ma de chevaux dans la
voiture me dis ben écoute installe-toi
la maison et partons ensemble sur pen
duick 6dans qu'eric c'était une vie
on est une chance pour chacun voilà donc
il ya des gens très différents michel
desjoyeaux jean le cam a alors on est
tous moi j'ai fait mon service militaire
avec eric et c'était un monsieur qui
avait une passion pour les vernis
anciens et qu'ils étaient en projection
permanente dans le futur donc il a
inventé le premier bateau en aluminium
le premier feuilles leur avec paul
ricard alors c'est vrai qu'à cette
époque on ne maîtrisait pas les
matériaux composites et pour faire voler
un bateau il faut concilier extrême
légèreté pour décoller tôt et très
grande solidité car les efforts sont peu
près deux fois supérieur à ce qu'on
trouve sur une voilure d'airbus voilà
donc eric était en avance sur son temps
ça n'était pas possible
il en rêvait effectivement je les fais
donc c'est un homme au côté duquel j'ai
eu la chance de passer trois ans et je
crois qu'on manque aujourd'hui de
d'ouverture dans cette société née
société cloisonnée
pas de chance aux jeunes des barrières
entre les générations et avec eric on
faisait travailler des retraités
d'assaut et d'airbus et ont donné une
chance aux jeunes voilà ce sont ce sont
des valeurs qui manque aujourd'hui pour
construire des projets on le voit bien
quand on passe aujourd'hui du diesel
électriques pour les voitures que de
barrières que de poids des lobbys du
vieux monde donc voilà j'ai eu la chance
de passer des moments extraordinaires
avec eric qui était en projection
permanente
alors on va reparler dans un instant de
votre dernier projet le syble mais
d'abord avec richard j'aimerais qu'on
alors il quitte la balle mais on reste
sur l'eau enfin au dessus de l'eau les
foils en réalité on les a d'abord vu sur
des bateaux à moteur absolument échapper
à la résistance de l'eau c'est un vieux
rêve d'architecte naval alain thébault
en a parlé effectivement c'est d'abord
sur des bateaux sur des bateaux à moteur
on le voit la c1 c'est un essai en
angleterre ans nés en 1952 il décollait
à peine mais c'est surtout les
militaires qui vont s'intéresser de très
près aux foils là on voit une celui de
70 selon envers un autre après favand 71
il était présenté dans la rade de brest
voilà celui là pendant la brade de
toulon et avant on a vu que une autre
d'autres bateaux qui vont s'intéresser
aux foils évidemment c'est les ferries
et on va les voir et on en verra on
envoie toujours beaucoup d'ailleurs ça
c'est vraiment répondu on en voit sur la
manche ou sur le méditerranée
une technologie qui arrivent dans notre
quotidien sur sur nos rivières
sur la scène également mais oui parce
que donc vous l'avez dit nathanel tout à
l'heure c'est votre
c'est votre dernier chant c'est votre
nouveau chantier enfin votre chantier en
cours alain thébault ce sont des bateaux
taxis qui s'élève au-dessus de l'eau des
petits bateaux taxis vous en avez fait
plusieurs présentations en 2017 et on va
le voir tout de suite une en 2018 sur la
scène écologique et les siebel se
propulse sans bruit ni rejet de carbone
sous le bateau des ailes immergé
permettent à partir d'une certaine
vitesse de soulever la bulle qui avance
on se maintenant à 50 cm au dessus de
l'eau à la alain thébault ournée ce
projet sea bulk les plus que lens et
quand verra-t-on en france sur la seine
à paris ou ailleurs des petites navettes
comme ça s'est levé hors de l'eau est
allé déposer bad et pourquoi pas des
journalistes à france télévisions vous
êtes bien placé français vision au bord
de l'eau effectivement c'est pour demain
là nous avons embauché dans notre start
up une dizaine de personnes donc avec
les meilleurs représentants les
meilleurs des écoles françaises donc on
a un politicien centralien super héros
un gadz'arts donc il ya une équipe vous
avez vu évoluer sur la scène le proof of
concept
aujourd'hui il faut passer d'une phase
bricolage dans notre garage à une phase
industrielle
donc ça ça prend quelques temps il ya
quelques ajustements mais là nous
démarrons la production des 50 premiers
bubble à hydrogène et donc nous verrons
dans un envolée sur la scène vous pouvez
les commandez avec une ap humble je suis
pas dans ma france télévisions je vais
aller remercier anne hidalgo d'avoir mis
autant de vélo dans la ville je clique
hôtel de ville
j'ai humble à 3 minutes katchou bubble
et ensuite c'est transporté mois et
autant il est difficile de faire une
voiture autonome autant humble autonome
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on en n'est pas
très loin et nous avons surtout des
demandes à la fois pour les jeux
olympiques de madame hidalgo la même
perez mais aussi aux états unis en asie
d'engins de plus grande capacité
parce qu'effectivement c'est bateau qui
vole c'est certes bien pour gagner le
vendée globe
s'ils ne perdent pas les feuilles le
chemin et c'est bien surtout pour la
mobilité
parce que faire voler un bateau c'est
moins de vagues c'est moins de pollution
c'est - - - c'est moins de bruit quand
on utilise hydrogène donc aujourd'hui on
coche toutes les cases pour développer
un projet de cette mobilité
et c'est la fibre inventif française
donc effectivement on est à cheval sur
les deux pays france et suisse parce
qu'on a trouvé nos piles à combustible
en suisse mais clairement ce sont ce
sont des projets de demain
les revenus aux folles d'alain thébault
ça fait trente ou quarante ans que vous
êtes dans l'eifel
est ce que le projet siebel aurait pu
être possible sans l'hydroptère non non
parce que tout le monde me dit alain tu
es un visionnaire d une vision pour les
folles une vision pour l'hydrogène etc
il y a des étapes imposées il ya tout
d'abord un papier une boîte de caran
d'ache on réfléchit et ensuite petit à
petit donc on arrive sur sur catia de
dassault systèmes mais il faut du temps
en fait un programme comme le rafale un
avion de combat ce ses 20 ans
aujourd'hui on parle d'avion et l'hydro
à hydrogène ça sera dans vingt ou trente
ans donc les ruptures technologiques
prennent du temps
et puis il y à il ya des aléas c'est la
technique c'est toujours plus longs plus
compliqué plus coûteux mais mais voilà
c'est le prix comme le disait baisse
mais mme nelson mandela bay soit je
gagne soit j'apprends alors nous souvent
moi j'ai gagné une ou deux fois et mais
la plupart du temps j'apprends alain un
mot sur sur le vendée globe la qui vient
de débuter
bien entendu vous regardez toutes les
heures je ne sais pas mais régulièrement
qui est en tête il ya un record dans
cette compétition de 74 jours et ce qui
va être battu je le pense oui
probablement
il y en a bien qui réussiront à passer
entre les gouttes
la difficulté c'est un peu comme si on
avait lancé trois 33 avions dans le ciel
au milieu d'une pluie de containers qui
volent et météorites c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui la mer et une poubelle
c'est une catastrophe donc j'en ai
discuté avec le souverain le prince
albert ii de monaco on est consterné
cible et quand vous naviguez aujourd'hui
vous tapez dans une bille de moi une
bâche plastique influent un container
qui flottent entre deux eaux donc
certains passent entre les gouttes
mais mon camarade de cam est parti sans
foils parce qu'à pour gagner avant tout
il faut arriver
alain thébault merci beaucoup pour votre
témoignage et vos explications
tiens vous parliez de
de la situation en mer vous parlez d'une
mère qui ressemble à une poubelle
ben ça me donne l'occasion de présenter
votre livre qui rend hommage à
l'environnement et à votre travail ainsi
qu'à celui de bertrand piccard un de vos
amis pionniers d'un monde durable
c'est votre histoire racontée en photo
par un journaliste qui vous suit depuis
de nombreuses années voilà comme chaque
semaine nous terminons cet inattendu par
une pépite de l'ina vous connaissez les
shadoks célèbre série d'animation
humoristiques diffusés sur la première
chaîne de l'ortf entre 1968 et 1973
eh bien regardez cet extrait qui prête à
réfléchir
figurez vous qu'un jour les shadoks
leurs êtres chers et de résistance ils
furent plus des comptes
les bons jours était fini
j'avais attrapé la maladie
dès qu'il y avait quelque part une
nouvelle planète bien bury d'habitants
qui apparaît c'est top
elle faisait dans le temps et elle en
faisait séjour ils ont bourré sabrina
ils ont été tellement de mal a dit qu'il
n'en restait même plus assez pour mourir
de façon normale et officiels si on peut
dire alors il dire qu'il fallait faire
quelque chose et que demain matin à la
première heure s en occuperait à
condition que d'ici là ils soient pas
tous trépasser voilà les shadoks avec la
voix de claude piéplu merci à l'eau
documentaliste ln2 dont magali verma et
delphine des biens qui nous ont aidés à
préparer cette émission se retrouvent
mercredi prochain 21 heures canal 27 et
toute la semaine sur les réseaux sociaux
de france info et de lina bonne semaine
[Musique]
c